niemand möchte an ihn erinnert werden
Lenin Symbolfigur der Sowjetunion wie
hier im ukrainischen harkif fallen
überall seine Statuen doch in einem
Berliner Museum ist Lenins Kopf eines
der wichtigsten Exponate warum nimmt der
russische revolutionär hier einen so
prominenten Platz ein und wo ist der
Rest der Statue
geblieben in einem Wald östlich von
Berlin geben wir uns mit dem
amerikanischen Filmemacher Rick minnick
auf Spurensuche nach einem
verschwundenen Denkmal aber auch nach
einer umstrittenenden historischen
Figur Minik führt uns dorthin wo er vor
30 Jahren den Kopf Lenins fand und
ausgrub der Ort ist nur für Eingeweihte
zu finden ja der
Kopf der Kopf muss ungefähr hier gelegen
haben und die anderen Teile sind drum
herum mein das das denk mal war 19 m
hoch und es waren 130
ungefähr 130 Teile und die mussen alle
noch hier sein
irgendwo aber wir haben trotzdem zwei
Tage gebraucht um den Kopf zu finden wir
haben erstmal andere Teile gefunden und
wir hatten auch nur Schaufel und
Eimer diesen Moment hielt er in einem
preisgekrünten Film fest ja eingebuddelt
ein Amerikaner auf der Suche nach
leninstatuen na ja es war ein sehr
schönes Gefüh da wow der der liegt
tatsächlich hier
ganz friedlich das war wirklich so als
ob als ob
er wie ein Mensch beerdigt war richtig
in der Erde lag und ich glaube der
sollte einfach der Gedanke damals von
den
Entscheidungsträgern war dass er einfach
vergessen werden sollte und ich meine
mein Kollegen ich wollten ein Zeichen
setzen dass man so eine wichtige
politische Figur historische Figur nicht
einfach verschwinden lassen so auf dem
ehemaligen leninplatz in Ostberlin
tronte einst die Statue am heutigen der
Vereinten Nationen liegen stattdessen
Steine aus aller Welt Rick Minck trifft
die Journalistin Marita Adam K zu
ddrzeiten wohnte sie mit ihrer Familie
hier musste mit ansehen wie das Denkmal
nach der wiedereinigung einfach abgebaut
wurde ja das war ein ganz seltsames
Gefühl weil der Lenin also wie man ihn
immer vorher betrachtet haben mag äh er
gehörte hier dazu und jetzt wurde
er so sang und klanglos sollte er in die
Grube fahren er
war ja wie eine entrückte Filmfigur ein
ein ein ein Gott ein Heiliger später
dann natürlich im Studium
habe ich ihn mehr und mehr
gesehen als historische Persönlichkeit
die glaube ich wie kaum ein anderer
die weltenläufte im 20 Jahrhundert
bestimmt hat Lenin eines von rund 150
Pseudonymen von Vladimir iljitch uljanov
doch als Lenin ging er in die Geschichte
ein im Februar 1917 verjagt eine
bürgerliche Revolution den letzten
russischen zarren eine provisorische
Regierung übernimmt die Macht Lenin
kehrt aus dem Schweizer Exil zurück und
putscht sich im Oktober 1917 mit einer
kleinen Truppe von bolschwiiki an die
Macht Lenin macht den Weg für den roten
Terror frei Gewalt ist für ihn elementar
um seine Ziele zu erreichen Lenin will
eine eine Gewalt der sozialen Konflikte
das heißt eine bürgerkriegsartige Gewalt
gegen ganze Klassen damit wird seine
Gewalt aber nur noch größer und das sagt
er von Anfang an er sagt auch wenn er
Bündnisse eingeht etwa mit der riesigen
Bauernschaft die für Russland so wichtig
ist sollten Sie sich dann doch
kleinbürgerlich Geberden wird der Kampf
gegen sie zu führen sein und das heißt
für ihn immer wieder dass Aristokraten
Bürger Bauern als Klassen vernichtet
werden diese
äh Gewaltbereitschaft deutet er nicht
nur an sondern will er regelrecht als
Ideologie als Strategie in seiner
Bewegung
verfestigen als Lenin im Januar 1924
stirbt ist Stalin bereits der mächtigste
Mann er lässt Lenin Einbalsamieren
errichtet in Moskau ein Mausoleum Lenin
wird zur Erlöserfigur isiert die Stalins
Gewaltherrschaft den Nimbus einer
gerechten Gesellschaftsordnung verleihen
soll Lenin wird damit verbunden und es
wird ein Mythos erzeugt aber im Grunde
ist es der falsche Prophet wenn man sich
seine seine seine Taten anschaut seine
Programme anschaut dann steht diese Art
von Sozialismus nie für einen
Sozialismus mit menschlichem
antitz doch genau dieser Mythos
überstrahlt auch in der DDR den hist
len 1970 wird die leninstatue in
Ostberlin enthüllt als Symbol der
deutschsowjetischen
Freundschaft das sozialistische
Wohnensemble um die Statue bildet ein S
und ein U für
Sowjetunion
1991 beschließ die Bezirksverordneten
Versammlung Berlin Friedrichs Hein das
Denkmal verschwinden zu lassen ein
Ereignis das später im Film goodby Lenin
ikonisiert wird auch wenn in der Fiktion
statt eines Krans ein Hubschrauber den
Kopf
[Musik]
abtransportiert nachdem Minik die Statue
1994 anhand eines Fotos ausfindig und
die Öffentlichkeit auf ihren Verbleib
aufmerksam gemacht hatte dauerte es
weitere Jahre bis ein Museum den Kopf
schließlich bergen
konnte in der Zitadelle in Berlin
Spandau hat Lenins Kopf inzwischen eine
neue Heimat gefunden umgeben von anderen
fragwürdigen denkmäln aus 200 Jahren
deutscher Geschichte liegt er hier auf
der Seite ganz ohne Siegerpose
Urte eevert leitet das Museum sie
erzählt wie Lenins Kopf hier immer
wieder für Diskussionen sorgt also es
ist unser Anliegen hier die Erinnerung
nicht zu verstecken und nicht zu
vergraben sondern wieder hochzuholen um
Menschen die Möglichkeit zu geben am
Originalobjekt über das nachzudenken was
in der Geschichte passiert ist und was
man für die Zukunft daraus lernen kann
und ich glaube wirklich dass wenn man
sich mit Lenins leben also mit der
echten Person auseinandersetzt und sich
vom Mythos dabei so ein kleines bisschen
äh entfernt dann auch etwas darüber
lernen kann wie ähm eine ein Mensch eben
auch so unterschiedlich
sein kann dass man das auch aushalten
muss dass man da jetzt weder ein Monster
noch ein heiligen hat dass aber eben
trotzdem die wirklich schrecklichen
Taten die er zu verantworten hat nicht
vergessen werden also deswegen kann ich
nur empfehlen sich da mehr mit Lenin
auseinander zuusetzen und auch mit
seiner Nutzung die ja auch durchaus noch
weiterhin von Diktator
Putin gemacht wird Putin nutzt Lenin
allerdings nicht als Säulenheiligen
sondern um ihn für das Ende des
russischen Imperiums verantwortlich zu
machen kurz vor dem Einmarsch in die
Ukraine behauptete Putin Lenin habe die
moderne Ukraine geschaffen das Lenin der
Ukraine im Gründungsvertrag der
Sowjetunion das Recht auf
Selbstbestimmung zugestand bezeichnete
Putin als so wörtlich Zeitbombe unter
dem Gebäude der
Staatlichkeit Lenin ist längst keine
respektierte historische Figur mehr für
Putin taugt er nur noch als Sündenbock
als jemand über den man sich lustig
machen kann so fät ihm nichts anderes
ein als quasi als Vordenker und
Gründungsvater seines hauptfeindes
Ukraine zu
beschuldigen im eigenen Land verspottet
im Westen verdammt noch immer fällt ein
nüchterner Blick auf Lenin schwer eines
ist jedenfalls klar ohne Rick minnick
dürfte der leninkopf wohl immer noch
unter der Erde begraben liegen und
könnte nicht als Anstoß für eine längst
überfällige Debatte
dienen
[Musik]